today Walmart has been able to regain
the momentum that they had lost in the
2000s over the past seven years their
stock has tripled it and their
fundamentals have led the way in fact
Walmart is the number one Revenue driver
in the entire world pulling in a crazy
600 billion dollars per year now I do
want to note that their earnings have
not kept up with the revenue growth but
this isn't really a concern the main
reason for this is simply that Walmart
has been investing much of their profits
into the tech side of the business and
the revenue growth and for modern
companies growth is simply way more
valuable than the bottom line Amazon for
example is still not profitable but
they're worth over a trillion dollars so
it looks like Walmart has not only
adopted the modern tech but they've
adapted to the modern business landscape